foreign
it's an absolute privilege to have you
here with us it's so good to be here
welcome to Stanford and welcome back to
the Bay Area yes it's so good to be in
the Bay Area and it's actually good to
be on Stanford's campus I am a Berkeley
grad but I wore red today for everybody
I wore red today
we are so blessed here in the Bay Area
to have just such fabulous fabulous
schools so it's good to be here oh it's
good to be here it's it's an honor well
before we dive in okay I believe we were
able to find some pictures of yours from
over the years oh my goodness and I'd
love to share some of them with the
audience if that's all right okay you go
right ahead
laughs so this is you oh Lord in college
oh my gosh you're at Berkeley as you
mentioned you're part of the
cheerleading squad do you remember this
picture yeah I think we won the big game
that year oh okay
well if you beat Stanford we'll move
right along I can remember that picture
oh my goodness I should bring that afro
back
and this is used several decades later
oh my goodness you're you're now the CEO
of the Dallas Mavericks yes you're still
cheering and somehow it looks to me like
you've got just as much energy as when
you were 19. yeah I do I do I do a lot
of energy uh just uh taking care of
myself enjoying life having a Passion
about what I do every day I mean when
you have a passion about what you do
every day you just get up with energy I
mean a lot of times people will ask the
question what keeps you up at night I
said no to me the question is what gets
you up in the morning it's about truly
doing something that gets you up in the
morning and you just wake up with energy
you work up with Pat wake up with
passion and so I'm just fired up all the
time I mean people ask my husband and my
kids are like does she like that all the
time my sister tell yes I'm like this
all the time yes yes something for all
of us to emulate for sure that's right
think about what gets you up in the
morning that's the question you want to
be able to answer since you have an
incredible Story and there's so much
that's transpired in between these two
pictures yes but I'd love to start at
the very beginning okay you grew up in
Easter Hill not too far from here in
Richmond California that's right and you
grew up in what most people would
describe to be very difficult
circumstances
um your mother at the time said that
it's not about out where you live but
how you live yes tell us about Easter
Hill and what did your mother mean by
that okay I love that question and uh
you've probably heard me say before that
despite some of the things that happen
because we all face adversity I actually
believe I had a good childhood and I
believe some of the things that I saw
and experienced are just things that
people see and experience in their
childhood and so my parents moved from
the from Birmingham Alabama so if you
know your civil rights history which I
hope you do especially with this being
Black History Month there was a church
in Birmingham Alabama the 16th Street
Baptist Church that was bombed where
four
little girls lost their lives actually
two others lost their lives afterwards
and then there was also the Bethel
Street Baptist Church where Reverend
Shuttlesworth his place there was bombed
those churches are the churches that my
mom grew up in the churches that my mom
attended and so she left in March of
1960 when I was three months old because
so that was I was the baby and then Ross
came after we came to uh stand up Rosa
waiver everybody stand up away with
everybody
laughs
so she was the first one born out here
in the in California okay uh so and then
I have a brother who was born after that
so six of us grew up in the Easter Hill
public housing uh project and my mother
stressed education yeah um and and
that's when she would say it's not where
you live it's how you live uh ZIP code
doesn't matter education does and so my
father stressed it as well his line was
get your lesson get your lesson meaning
you know take care of your your
educational business and so we so we
grew up knowing that that was important
um but I also had some things that
happened uh when I was 11 years old I
saw my father actually shoot a man in
the head and it was in self-defense
because this young man who we actually
went to church with approached our house
and so we were all in the back room and
my mother had us all in the back and you
know I wanted to be nosy believe it or
not and Ross can attached to it I was
actually a fairly quiet kid we handled
our business but I was nosy and and saw
this commotion was at the front door and
I sneaked out because I wanted to know
what was going on and that's when my
father in self-defense shot this man
because the silver pistol was pointed
down at me and my father was going to do
whatever he had to do to defend his
family fortunately it wasn't fatal but
you can imagine the chaos that broke out
in our family and so we had to be
sequestered in the house but some of us
said we got to go to school and I said I
got to go to school because I just I
love school I loved it and so my mother
had a uniform police officer officer
Darrell Prater to take me to school in
the seventh grade and he'd either get on
the bus with me or he'd put me in his
police car like he never put the siren
or anything on but he got me to school
and in fact when I got this job and they
had all that detail put all this detail
on me I said you don't have to explain
it to him I had Secret Service when I
was 11 years old
I know I know how this stuff works and
so and then four years later my parents
got a divorce uh ugly uh bloody divorce
my father broke my nose when I was 15
years old and so I went back to school
with a brace on my nose and that's when
three teachers and a principal found out
what was going on really embraced me
knew that my mom had a desire for all of
her kids to go to college and so Roz and
I decided we were going to be the first
ones to graduate from a big four-year
school and make it happen others were
doing you know their own thing but we
had these big dreams about going to
college and so the rest is history I
ended up getting five full scholarships
to the College of my choice yeah and
chose Berkeley because it was close to
home and normally what I say is not
because it's the number one public
institution in the world okay so public
okay public but it was it was close to
home and one of my scholarships came
with the car and all that and so I
wanted to stay close to home with my
younger brothers and sisters and my mom
and so I got a great great education my
ZIP code didn't matter and so that's my
desire these days for in our country the
ZIP code should not matter that everyone
should be afforded the great education
that I was able to get that Ross was
able to get my other cousin Roz here
stand up cousin Ross
it's so good to have these honeys
it's so good to have them here because
usually I'm kind of in and out of
California and so
I never get to see them but somehow they
caught me so I'm so glad I'm so glad
you're here so anyway but we we were
blessed to get a great education and so
that's what my mother what she meant
about it's not where you live it's how
you live it's about handling your
business getting your education having a
set of values that you stand on I mean
we had a set of values that we stood on
faith was important uh really important
I mean she kept us in church we were
those kids on the front row you know we
were in the front Pew and you have to
behave your mother my mother would look
down for the choir stand and you just
couldn't act up okay and so we were
raised very disciplined and to be very
respectful and to work hard and that's
what we saw even through adversity we
were taught that we had to kind of make
it through it yeah and so we did and so
all that is a part of my foundation and
the values that I was raised on and that
I have are the values honestly that I
bring into the workplace wherever I go
yeah and you mentioned the scholarships
and getting to go to the College of your
choice yes before you enrolled you had
an interesting conversation with your
boyfriend at the time
what did you tell
us that's what I told him okay so during
my first week in college I mean it was a
big deal for me yeah I mean you know
going uh you know stepping foot on
Berkeley's campus and I actually
remember I started in the summer and
seeing everything big the Sailor gate I
mean just all that and you know how it
is when you step foot on a campus I mean
you've all been there it's just a whole
different experience right and my first
week in college my boyfriend I kind of
had like two but you know my distant
boyfriend uh my distant boyfriend you
know hey until you put a ring on it okay
and so
so my distant boyfriend he called it he
says I am three he says I changed
schools because he was in Fresno so in
the Central Valley and Fresno and Clovis
and he says I've changed schools I met
San Francisco State University now so
that I can be close to you now this is
my first week in college now that sounds
sweet right
he says so surprise I'm across the
bridge I said surprise boyfriend uh I I
got news for you I got a surprise for
you I will call you when I graduate so I
saw him once after that he'd actually go
my sister's going to test to it he'd go
and see my mom and tell my mom he was
going to marry me and all that but I
needed to handle my business so I just
because I just didn't want to be bogged
down and so what I told him is I didn't
have time for some smooth talking cutie
he wanted to play when I needed to study
I wanted to enjoy my experience but also
handle my business and so the day I
graduated from college I called him you
did exactly what you said you were going
to do and so he couldn't appreciate that
though he said
I said I said hi this is Sid I said
Kenny this is sin he says sin who I said
wait a minute boy don't act like you
don't know me okay because I know he had
been keeping in contact with my mom and
all that I said don't act like you don't
know me and I was fired up I said I just
graduated from uh college and I'm so
fired up I got this job at the phone
company where he was actually working at
the time and his dad actually retired
from there and I was just fired up about
my future my family's future all that
and he said who is this again I said
don't act like you don't know who I am
my mom is having a party at six o'clock
she's still there in eastern Hill but
she's gonna get now be at the party six
o'clock and he said he couldn't come to
the party because he was engaged
that's the wrong answer
okay and so he says I haven't talked to
you in almost four years and I said well
I kept my end of the bargain I told you
I was going to call you when I graduated
I just graduated at two o'clock it's
three o'clock like you waited an hour
okay so in his mind is four years and by
buying it's an hour I did what I said I
was gonna do well anyway
uh on April the 30th of this year I will
be married to that boy for 40 years wow
so yeah yeah
thank you
he came just incredible he came to the
party so whenever we move our kids into
college or one of our nieces or nephews
after we move them all in I got my whole
mommy routine where I decorate the dorm
rooms and do all that and so right
before we leave he says uh I think
there's a phone call that you're
supposed to make this is where you take
your boyfriend and girlfriend and put
them on hold until you graduate I guess
patience truly is a virtue it really is
I tell them all the time he was that
close to missing out on his Blessing I
mean like that close that close but he
didn't so you graduate from Berkeley I
believe you had 13 job offers you did
your homework you
thank you
and and out of all these options you
chose a t where you started at age 21
and you stayed and reached some of the
highest levels of the organization at
the very beginning though what did you
want from your career what was most
important to you okay so when I was uh
interviewing on campus I had two
criteria like only two I said I wanted
the job that paid me the most money okay
and I wouldn't advise that but that's
kind of where I was a lot a long time
ago I want the job that pays me the most
money and back then they paid me six
thousand sixteen thousand two hundred
dollars a year okay that was way long
time ago so I want the job that paid me
the most money but also a job where I
could be the boss at 21 years old and it
wasn't really about being the boss it
was about leading people and serving
people okay because I had had some
leadership experience just you know in
in life activities and all that but I
wanted a job where I could truly serve
people and so at T had a fast track
management program and I started out
supervising and I don't know anything
about this I'm trying to look around at
the ages in here back in the day when
you would dial zero to actually and that
was like not even cell phones okay to
get your calls uh made and so I
supervised those operators in San
Francisco oh okay and so I worked the
night shift because I was I like night
classes and evening classes I didn't
like to get I'm not a morning person and
that's why the timing of this is perfect
like if this was the breakfast it was
like but this is perfect and so I'm an
eye person and so I supervise these
operators and it was great to this day
those operators and the union employees
they taught me just about everything I
know about my leadership leadership
philosophy to this day they taught me
how to truly serve how to walk into a
place when you really don't know
anything and I was very honest I walked
in I said okay it's my first job I don't
know anything and they're laughing like
we know you don't know anything okay we
already know that but I told them I was
willing to learn and that I knew my job
was to serve them okay and to make their
lives better personally and
professionally and so they put me
through the paces they had all a list of
things that they had wanted to do and
management would listen to them so here
they had this 21 year old and they would
give me the list and say sit let's try
this let's try that and so I'm 21 years
old I'm like okay that sounds good and
then I would go to my boss and she said
oh no we can't do this so this one uh
project with this one policy in
particular I wanted to change and these
operators had been working on it for
years and to me it was kind of like an
inhumane policy where they had to sign
up to go to bathroom all kind of stuff
because of course you know you're trying
to you know look at call volumes and
traffic and so they said no we want the
we want the company to trust us okay and
here's how we want to how how we want to
do this so they laid it all out I said
okay and so I convinced my boss to let
us try it wow and she didn't want to try
it but we did our results went from the
worst in the company
literally to the best in the company
because we listened to the people who
were closest to the work and they knew
we trusted them they held each other
accountable and we changed the whole
system for the company actually across
the United States so it's developing
that trust while maintaining your
commitment to service well yeah you have
to serve them when you walk into a job
yes you're the boss but all that means
is you are here to serve these people
and so I have a leadership philosophy
that's based on Three L's
and I believe as a leader if I want to
truly be effective I only need to do
three things and that and I need to do
them extremely well listen to the people
learn from the people and love the
people and truly love them as people not
as employees not as at T employees not
as a Mavs employee not where you know
you will people walk into a phone booth
and then they put on a cape and they
have a big T or M on their chest that's
not who I want the person who gets up
out of bed in the morning
the issues they have the problems they
have the backgrounds they have the
dreams they have all of that is what I
want to walk into my doors and when that
person walks into my doors I need to be
able to meet them where they are and
really serve them and that means I need
to really love them for who they are not
try to change them to be somebody else
but accept that person I need to listen
to them when I first got to the Mavs I
spent literally 90 days I met with every
single employee in the organization
every single employee and I would start
off with the same question I'd say okay
not a question of statement I said tell
me about yourself like give me your
whole life story and undoubtedly they
would start off and say oh this is my
fifth season at the Mavs or this is my
seventh season at the mass I said were
you born here
like I want your life story
and the reason that's important because
I want to know who's sitting in front of
me and then we talk about all kind of
math stuff and then I said okay tell me
where you see yourself five years from
now personally and professionally
because I really believe my job as a
leader and our job as an executive
leadership team is to help you get there
personally and professionally we have to
invest in you but you don't know that if
you don't listen to people and truly let
them talk and then you have to learn
about their job learn about what they do
when I was at ATT I went to pole
climbing School the the installers were
probably four levels below me but I went
to pole climbing school because I wanted
to be able to appreciate what they were
going through every day so I could
really serve them and give them what
they needed so you listen to the people
learn from the people and really love
them as people not as employees that's
my secret yeah and you use those
leadership principles to really seek
advancement at ATT but the process of
advancement wasn't always easy I think
in your book you mentioned the Congress
station where you're up for promotion to
the officer level at at T and your boss
is calling to congratulate you but
there's some conditions attached and
maybe even some problems with your name
man you really did okay
yes okay so first of all I never I uh I
turned down four promotions okay in my
career because either there was or one
reason or another and usually it was
because there was something else I
wanted to learn about the company uh
after my first job with these operators
I actually got a job offer they wanted
me to be uh to replace my boss she was
getting ready to retire and they wanted
me to be the second level manager I
turned that down because here I am you
know 22 23 years old I plan to have a
career with this company I want to know
more than just operator Services I mean
I'm working in a technical company and
so I ended up taking a job as a network
engineer because I wanted to know about
the company so it was a lateral move but
then I had a boss tell me he says okay
you can't just keep accepting lateral
moves you got to start moving up
especially I was on this fast track
Management program so I never sought
advancement I never I knew I was
supposed to get to director level within
five years my family was pulling for me
everybody kind of wanted it to happen
and so once that happened I was like
okay I I just want to enjoy my career
but things positive things kept
happening because I was actually
delivering the goods leading people and
so good things were happening so when I
finally get this call uh 25 years into
it to be an officer I just walked in the
house my boss called and she said
congratulations the company just uh
named you the board just elected you to
be an officer of the corporation and I
said officer of the corporation I mean I
knew what it was I was already in a big
VP job at my San Francisco office down
on New Montgomery Street and so I was
already doing great
delivering a lot of good policy for the
company and just doing some great things
and so it actually caught me off guard
because I did I wasn't trying to do it
and so my husband is in the background
and he's smiling and I said Okay and she
says Okay so
let me let me give you some advice let
me tell you some things that I want and
she said I just left a magazine on your
desk so when you get back to work you'll
see a magazine she said I think it was a
Black Enterprise Magazine she said there
are all these black people on the cover
they're wearing white and the ladies
have short hair so I think you would
look great in white and I think you will
look great in a short haircut and she
starts describing this haircut and I'm
thinking what does this have to do with
the job but she in her mind was coaching
me and giving me some you know ideas on
how to step into this officer role then
she said and you're gonna have to change
your name
you can't be sent no sense you have to
be Cindy or Cynthia because nobody knows
what a scent is nobody ever heard of
that wow well I heard of it I've been
sent my whole life and and Mo and most
of the people that I grew up with black
people named Cynthia with the exception
of my sister had a friend named Cindy
Holloway that's only black Cindy I knew
okay so I knew people Ascent but she
didn't so she wanted me to change my
name and so then she said and you know
people are in your office all the time
because you know you're that's a place
where people just want to come they feel
like they can talk to you and all that
you're going to have to stop talking to
all these people and so she and then you
know of course what she wanted me to
wear so she literally just started
giving me this whole picture that was
not me now coaching is one thing because
we're all you know we all need to be
coached because sometimes you're in
environments that are new the culture is
new all that you need to know how to
show up but then when you start talking
like this it's getting kind of crazy but
here's where it kind of went over the
edge she says and you have to stop using
the word blessed you have to use the
word lucky I said what if I don't think
I'm lucky
and she says well I mean yeah so what if
I don't think I'm lucky then I think I'm
blessed she goes no no no churchy kind
of words you can't do any of that and
that's when I said okay so here's what
we're going to do I said I need you to
tell them help me figure out how to tell
the company no
that I'm not going to accept this
officer promotion because my sense is
you are fundamentally trying to change
who I am and you know what when my first
week in the company
I had a boss who made me get rid of my
red shoes and my braids and I came home
and had to stay up all night with my
family taking down my braids and here it
is some 19 20 years later
and this is still going on but the
difference is I'm a different person and
so I'm not going to accept this and so
she helped me come up with the words
because my biggest concern is I don't
want to lose my current job I got a big
job and I'm doing great I'm taking care
of my family so I don't want to lose my
current job but I'm not going to accept
this because you're asking me to be
somebody else so she came up with the
words
and so she said okay I agree with you
because I guess I wasn't sophisticated
enough for something I don't know and so
but pretty much that's I mean that's
what she was saying and so
um that's where I left it and then a few
minutes later her boss called me and
then the chairman of atnt Ed Whitaker
called me and he started off he said
sent and he put the emphasis on the T
and he said girl let's start this all
over again I heard what happened and he
went and described me to a T and he said
that is the person who we just promoted
to be an officer that is the person who
we want to walk in the doors tomorrow
you don't need to change a thing he said
will you accept the offer to be an
officer of this Corporation and I said
absolutely and it was funny because my
husband was in the background hearing
this whole thing and when she was
telling me to change my hair and all
this and he's like I got a barber don't
worry about it I mean so like like he's
in the background trying to make it
happen he's like he's like whatever they
are asking you to do like you need to do
it and at some point you have to draw a
line you have to know who you are what
you stand for and I just said no so he
didn't like that but of course it ended
out it ended up being great and it was
the point in my career where words
matter when you are a leader words
matter
and his words actually made me finally
say I can be who I am I can tell stories
that normally I wouldn't tell I can open
up and be exactly who I am and that
actually has served me well since then
that's an incredible story and so
heartening to hear that you can maintain
your authenticity while still achieving
your your career goals just just truly
inspirational well you have to because
and here's and this is how I am with my
employees the people who are delivering
all those results and the people who are
making it happen and because people
deliver results they just don't like
happen so the people who are doing that
those are the people that you're
promoting and those are the people who
you want to continue to give to your
organization so why try to change them
and that's what diversity is all about
you want all of those differences around
the table you're not trying to create
all these people who look alike who are
wearing white with short hair say I'm
lucky yeah not trying to do that
so you're able to stick to your
conviction your and your principles
you're thriving in your career yes you
become president of at T in North
Carolina then comes a day in 2010 I
believe the day before New Year's Eve
and uh you you you have a lot of detail
in your book yeah you're kind of scaring
me okay
you are kind of scaring me where are you
getting all this from who are you
talking to now I'm wondering what in the
world at some point he's going to say
something that I think nobody knows
you have to be really like a big
Revelation to the world you've got an
incredible book and I had the
opportunity to read it doing that thank
you
uh it's it's a day before New Year's Eve
you receive a call from a doctor at this
point yes
um what's your first reaction
oh I just couldn't believe it I am I was
diagnosed with stage three colon cancer
uh one lymph node before stage four and
it was actually as a result of being in
a corporate athlete program
in May of that year and it was an
assessment of your physical mental
emotional health what I actually refer
to as PMS physical mental spiritual
health and we need to pay attention to
all of it all the time but I wasn't and
so in this assessment they ask you to
pick one thing that you would do that
would help you have better results and
so mine was the physical category
because the mental category was great
spiritual category was great has some
work to do on physical I didn't think I
had as much work to do as I thought
because I had already stopped eating my
fried chicken I had already stopped
eating my ding dongs I mean I just said
I wanted to get healthy right and I was
an athlete growing up I ran track and
all that and so I just wanted to be
healthy so I focused on that so the one
thing that I picked that I would do is
respond to a referral slip that had been
given to me the previous year my doctor
had given me a referral slip to get a
colonoscopy and I took that referral
slip and I put it on my nightstand
and honestly I can admit I never planned
on doing anything with it
because I'm feeling pretty good I'm
healthy I at that time I was 49 I said I
don't really need to do anything with
this and so I did so the one thing I
committed to as a result of this class
and this assessment because they're all
pressing us is all the officers right
they're pressing us to do one thing and
I said okay I will go and get the
colonoscopy song take that referral slip
off my nightstand I'll do that they gave
us these accountability buddies so I had
this one Frank Jules one of my buddies
out of New Jersey he called me every
morning and for some reason he'd always
catch me going through the Starbucks
line and he'd call and say hey girl you
get that thing done you get that thing
done and I said no stop calling me I
haven't yet so finally finally I
scheduled my colonoscopy and I ended up
having it the day before my 51st
birthday so technically I was in
compliance I was 50 years old my last
date a big 50. but I had that referral
slip I had received it quite a few
months before then and it came back uh
you know it came back basically saying
my doctor said get to a surgeon and so I
went to a surgeon he told me you know I
had this mass and he said it didn't look
like cancer so don't worry about it we
were coming back home to California for
the holidays he said don't cancel your
trip but you know what you have to
follow your instincts and nobody's going
to advocate for your health the way you
can and I told him I said well just
looking at this honestly I feel like
this tumor is growing like by the second
I need surgery and I sat in his office
on a Friday afternoon and I sat there
for an hour and a half because he said
he could not do surgery it wasn't urgent
this was just his professional opinion I
mean he's a fabulous surgeon but in his
professional opinion we could wait and I
just said I don't feel like I can wait
and so and so he asked my husband he
says is she going to leave here take a
note for an answer he goes my husband
said no you're going to have to find
somewhere to have surgery so they found
somewhere that Monday morning I ended up
having surgery and before I left the
hospital he actually said
um don't worry about the pathology
report and I said okay when is it coming
out and so he finally ended up calling
me and I had to track him down for five
days he finally ended up calling me the
day literally the day before New Year's
Eve and he said are you sitting down I
have news it's bad and it's significant
and I can just I mean I remember those
words like it was yesterday and he told
me
that I had cancer and that I didn't have
a day to spare and that I needed to get
to an oncologist
and I couldn't I just couldn't believe
it it was really it was the only time in
my life and I've gone through a lot in
terms of miscarriages the death of my
daughter my husband was brain damage I
mean I've gone through some things
this was an out-of-body experience I
really didn't think he was talking to me
and so my husband came over I cried and
all that but then I called my mother
because that's just what you do yeah I
called my mother and so she's here in
the Bay Area and I told her I had cancer
and she said okay she said this is for
His glory god will get the glory out of
this you have a high profile job you're
not going to die everybody's going to be
able to see that you've come through
this it's going to be used for a
positive story and you will tell this
story one day
I didn't want to hear any of that
because I was trying to have a pity
party because I had just been told that
I had cancer and the prognosis was not a
good one but she wouldn't go there and
pretty much told me that I had been
chosen for this
and so I ended up going through
chemotherapy everybody kind of rallied
around me my family my work family and
did what we needed to do it was brutal I
named my chemo prompt Winston from the
movie when Stella Got A Stella Got a
groove back in her her boyfriend was
Winston so I named my pump Winston
because that's my Gotta Give me my
groove back but I had a positive
attitude and decided I would focus on
the can in cancer and it was great
because my work family from all across
at T showed up for me I was in North
Carolina but of course had spent 25
years and grew up here just people
everywhere I showed up my church family
my you know my family it was an
experience that really proved to me why
my theme song in life is so important my
theme song in life is Ain't No Mountain
High Enough y'all kind of young but have
you ever heard that song and mine is the
upbeat Tammy Terrell Marvin Gaye version
somebody like the Michael McDonald
version too because diversity and
inclusion so I like the white man's
version too okay so I like the Black
Version I like the White Version okay
the Diana Ross version kind of slow for
me but so that's that's my theme song
Ain't No Mountain High Enough because of
the words okay and it basically says
whatever it is like you can call me and
we need to be there for each other and
so I sing it all the time because that's
the story of my life we always show up
for each other there's nothing we can't
accomplish no mountain that's too high
for us but this time in my life when I
got cancer that's when that song really
became life to me it really became life
you mentioned being chosen for this
journey in that in that conversation
with your mother and perhaps because you
were chosen you also felt a sense of
responsibility towards others yes yes I
think that sense of responsibility
really shines through in some letters
that you wrote to your employees that's
in your book as well
yes with your permission I'd love to
read a few lines from one of the letters
oh that'd be wonderful amazing
you are ready to do even bigger bigger
things in life we'll have to talk
because I'm always hiring there's
nothing
laughs
and you are from Dallas that's right
they'd love to have you back on your
parents love to have you back home and
you're from Dallas
to the audience we have some Texans in
the audience stand up Texans stand up
Texas
yes yes yes
everybody come back home we need help
so you have this this letter that you're
you're sending to all of your employees
just one week after your cancer
diagnosis you say some of you have
probably heard by now that I was
diagnosed last week with colon cancer
I will definitely beat this I'm uniquely
equipped for this battle
I have faith good common sense a
detail-oriented skill set aggressiveness
a great employer and Health Plan
wonderful family and friends and that
includes all of you
I will have just one more awesome
testimony when this is all over and my
three teenagers and husband will have a
lot more faith in God
thanks in advance for your love prayer
and support this will indeed be a happy
New Year yes indeed and I'm cancer free
yes it is
yes indeed
this just strikes me every time I read
it this is this is so striking and what
shines through is not only your
incredible optimism but also your
leadership at a very difficult time
where do you get this optimism from and
how do you use it to inspire other
people
I think it's naturally in my spirit I
saw it with my mother I saw her go
through a lot but always having hope and
being optimistic my sister would just
tell you it's just who we are I think
it's rooted honestly in scripture I try
to live my life by Jeremiah 29 and 11.
it says for I know the plans I have for
you plans to prosper and not harm you
plans to give you hope in the future so
I just truly believe there is a
wonderful wonderful plan for my life I
believe there's a wonderful plan for
your life and that it's all goodness and
greatness that we need to focus on and
yes we will have bad things happen I
often say sometimes the light at the end
of the tunnel is a train
bad things do happen to good people
sometime that light that you see is a
train coming to roll you over but
there's always I believe there's always
a hand that's going to get you back up
because sometimes you can't get up by
yourself so I just look for that hand to
get up and I look for
that light that is coming at me like a
train but then I know there's another
one coming and it's usually attached to
somebody who's going to help me and then
I often think about I need to be that
light for somebody I need to be the one
to make sure that they get up and so I
I'm wired that way I am just wired to
think that the glass is not just half
full but it is overflowing and so my
husband is wired just the opposite he's
like the glass is half empty I'm like
boy please okay the glass is half full
in fact it's overflowing and you gotta
go and get it and so that has worked for
me for 63 years and I don't think I'm
going to change I absolutely love that
and you apply these same principles to
the workplace as well yes you're able to
advance to the senior vice president
level at at T you become Chief diversity
officer you become an expert really in
organizational culture yes
what makes you so passionate about
culture sin and for all the Future
Leaders in the audience how should we be
thinking about building the right
culture it's all about people
people and and culture is is just very
simple in fact I saw I read something
last night that basically said you know
when you what kind of culture you have
by how your employees are feeling on
Sunday night
when they think about getting ready to
go back to work on Monday morning I
literally just just read that and so
when I got to the Mavs it was it was a
bad situation when I got that call from
Mark Cuban who I did not know by the way
when he called me I mean I just my
husband had to make me call him back
because I mean people laugh I didn't
know him he didn't know me okay but he
had gotten my name he had a situation
where he needed to really change his
organization and so somehow I had built
that reputation from working from
helping ATT
literally I let the effort to get us to
get ATT and the great Fortune's great
place to work list 100 best places to
work list for the first time ever and it
was about pulling people together giving
them a vision so that's what I did at
the Mavs when I got there the first
thing I did I gave them a vision that
said we would set the global standard
for diversity equity and inclusion and I
went there because I truly believe if
you have an inclusive culture and a
diverse group of employees you can get
anything done I mean it really is
McKenzie gives the business case others
give it as well I've lived it there's a
bottom line impact to having diversity
and having equity in your organization
and an inclusive culture and then I laid
out a set of values because culture 2 is
about having a foundation having a
common set of values that Embrace people
and that give us kind of a focus on
where we want to go how we want to do
business and our values at the MAV spell
crafts character respect authenticity
fairness teamwork and safety both
physical and emotional safety and then
we laid out our 100-day plan and made it
real clear that we are going to be a
place of zero tolerance for
inappropriate behavior misconduct false
allegations and all that but we were
going to have an Express agenda for
women because when I got to the Mavs
there were zero women in permanent
leadership positions and zero people of
color I don't know how you run an
organization like that and you don't tap
into the richness of the diversity
that's there so within 90 days we were
50 women around my table and 50 people
of color wow I'm like let's just go
ahead and get this thing laid out so we
can be successful but I want to drive a
message around an inclusive culture and
it's all about making sure that every
voice matters and everybody belongs and
that is our workplace promise Araceli is
down there she's on our team stand
aracely she's absolutely amazing
[Music]
and so we we work together we work
together to make sure that we deliver on
that leadership promise of every voice
matters and everybody belongs but the
tone is set at the top you can't ask all
your employee resource groups and your
people at the lower levels to uh
literally set that tone you have to set
the tone and then everybody Embraces
that and then we're all responsible for
the culture of the organization but you
have to make it real clear and you have
to demonstrate it you have to role model
it and that's what I try to do I don't
get it perfect every day but that's what
I try to do so you were brought into the
Mavs to really Drive change yes but
change often you know comes with
resistance yes so tell us about some of
the challenges you faced when you were
trying to drive change as a new CEO well
after I you know we we laid out this
hundred day plan and the 100 day plan
had 200 initiatives and so we wanted
everybody to kind of rally around them
obviously I knew I would have to make
some leadership changes diversify the
team
exit some people who had engaged in
misconduct or just you know didn't fit
anymore Etc
so I thought I had done all that and
then all of a sudden I realized there
was one group in particular they weren't
responding to our initiatives and they
weren't in on the meetings I mean
everybody's fired up about the things we
needed to do and so then they ended up
telling me that their boss had told them
not to engage not to listen to me that I
was just a PR stunt and I would be gone
in 90 days wow
I'd be five years at the end of this
month and he was gone in 90 days because
you can't have people around that
absolutely are fighting against the
culture now it's one thing you know you
got to bring people along and sometimes
they come along slowly but when you have
somebody who's totally resistant and who
thinks bad behavior is okay and then
they want to keep people down so their
people can't flourish
you're doing a disservice to the people
to everybody else now when I have to let
somebody go that is the hardest thing
I mean it's the hardest thing because
you're thinking about their livelihood
if they have kids and all that but in my
40 I guess two years now of being a
professional I have never fired anyone
they opt out they decide if they don't
want to work in a certain place they
decide that they don't want the culture
and so we had some people who made a
decision that they didn't want it and
for the sake of everybody else there
you're talking about loving the people
I have to ask myself do I love them
enough to put them out of their misery
because they gotta they want to engage
but they got to respond to this guy and
so we have to let him go and so we had a
few things we had a few items like that
but for the most part we had people who
want to come along they wanted to work
in a whole different kind of environment
and so that's what we're doing that's
just been good that's incredible and
your ability to bring people along while
also setting the vision is uh really
stands out since you've had an
incredible career you've been able to
drive impact in so many different roles
what's one thing you really want to be
remembered for
I often tell my kids
um
like if we go to a funeral or something
I tell them I only want one thing
written about me and said about me when
I leave and I plan on being here until
I'm 102.
because I said I got cancer at 51 so
that was my midlife crisis so I plan on
being here until 102. but when I'm 102
and I'm laid out I want them to write
she left it better than she found it
that's all I want to do is walk into a
place and know that there are people who
literally their lives have changed that
they are better because they met me that
they are better because I did something
in their life I actually got a letter
from an employee from an employee at our
American Airlines Center the other day
and it actually caught me off guard I
got this and I'm thinking okay I don't
know if this is a complaint I don't know
what this is I'm actually walking
through my house after our game went off
television
and I had to just stand there and catch
myself for about 10 minutes because this
woman had read my book and she goes
through a full page of all these
horrible things like horrible things
that had gone on in her life and how she
had given up
and then she said I read your book
and that day
my life changed
I'm gonna live and then she starts
describing all this great stuff that's
happening and her mindset had changed
she said I want you to know us because I
read your book you literally just saved
my life
I said wow I wrote the book to touch one
person that was the person and so that's
all I want to do is just leave it better
I want I don't I don't care about being
famous and all that I'm kind of famous
now but
but I don't really like care about all
that aracely will tell you when I even
when I get requests and it was said
earlier I could probably do this every
day but I try to pick the things that
truly would have impact that's why this
invitation was so special to me I mean
to be able to come in to the Stanford
Graduate School of Business where I
actually when I was a recruiter at ATT
this was one of my schools it's my top
school that I've come and recruited and
to be able to touch the lives of people
who are already accomplished
but who are here so you can learn even
more so you can make an even bigger
difference in the world to be able to
just say something whether it's the
Three L's or just something to help you
on your journey that's why I said yes to
this that's all I want to do is leave it
better than I found it well we're
delighted you accepted your leadership
authenticity and just optimism really
really shines through for all of us
should we take a few questions in the
audience I would love that y'all got
questions for me I would love that
one question over here
hi sin thank you for being here my name
is Kareem and I'm a second year MBA
student awesome thanks
that's awesome you're about to get out
of here huh it gets better I'm a huge
Maps fan go maps go Maps
I I played basketball professionally
before business school tried to develop
a fade away shot like Dirks never really
managed to do that he's really good my
question for you is also about people I
truly admire what you did for the
organization and hope that you can lead
us to Championship soon
um I'm just very curious to hear about
your approach to building consensus
especially when you work in a space
where you have to deal with very special
unique and strong personalities oh I
love that I love that question thank you
and thank you for thank you your loyalty
to the map you know we're in Sacramento
tonight and tomorrow night so if you
want to come you just let me know I got
connections
there you go I got it like that yes yes
yes yes yes
what I try to do the way I try to build
consensus is to first of all you need
Clarity you need true Clarity around
what is the problem what's the issue
you're trying to solve so often we are
that the things are muddy and so you're
talking about one thing I'm talking
about something else you're talking
about something else so I like to get my
team in a room and say okay what is the
issue where are we trying to go what are
we truly trying to solve and why are we
trying to solve this I'm a big why
person I will ask why 10 times why are
we trying to solve this because
sometimes you're addressing something
that actually doesn't even matter and we
don't have time for that we have to set
priorities we're not going to be
fighting over something that doesn't
even matter or something we shouldn't
even be talking about so once we get
through all that and realize it is
important and we have real clear
Direction on where we're trying to get
to
then I get everybody's opinion and I'm
not one of these people where I'm about
just the group talk or the loudest voice
I literally my team will tell you
aracely will tell you I go around the
table because I notice who's quiet and
so I'll go around the table and say okay
so let me hear from you
let me hear from you
let me hear from you and if you say oh
sin I don't really have an opinion yes
you do
you work here everybody has an opinion I
don't want you to take it home I don't
want you to give it to anybody else I
need you to give it to us
and so we'll go around and then and it's
not even about process of elimination
it's not about majority rules it's about
and then and then we bounce everything
up we'll have some you know some
solutions right and then we bounce them
up against our values every decision we
make we Bounce It Up Against crafts what
does it mean from a character standpoint
does it respect the people involved does
it allow them to be uh themselves is it
fair and fairness and like equality and
Equity fairness is not sameness
Samus is equality fairness is about
Equity are we meeting people where they
are so we take them through that whole
thing teamwork says we do all that and
then we make a decision what's best for
the organization not for any particular
individual what is best for the
organization sometime I lose I'll lose
or I will have an aha moment and when I
have my aha moment I make sure my team
members know that I said okay well it
sounds like scent was wrong on that one
and then I'll and then I'll go to
whoever kind of like put the issue out
there that gave me the aha moment and
I'll say thanks for sharing that because
I didn't see it that way I mean I really
thought whatever whatever whatever and
then other people will start to do the
same so then by everybody's still
talking about it because you have to
even talk you know you're taught not to
talk you are taught not to talk past the
cell when you're trying to build
consensus sometimes you do need to keep
talking because you need to get buy-in
people need to understand kind of how
you got there and then I have a rule
especially in my leadership team we all
walk out we walk out together you don't
walk out and say well I still don't buy
in no your partis leadership team we
talked it out and we think we made the
best decision for the organization
that's how we drive consensus a lot of
why and we test it against our values
and we talk about it even when we've
decided to make sure we get ownership
does that help well thank you for
sharing your perspective with us today
it's been a true honor sent Marshall
thank you thank you very much you're
amazing
[Applause]
[Music]